let's have a look at a light in case you
can't quite make it out your eyesight
like mine that reads 13 3 root 2 minus
47 1 have agreement yes fantastic 15
hands down you can see a lot of stuff
even though you start with so many
things but what if stuff does simplify
out before you even put pen to paper
when you look at that question what
clues are there in the question is that
actually what you ought to end up with
should it be quite simple anyone's
inclusive initiative in that people
these recipes are doing others what
these are called again like one of these
things why we call this binomial because
there are two terms and I know you me so
you go financial here binomial here do
you notice the answered conversation
you've got the rational part the 903 or
the negative 9 and the 3 they're
rational then you've got some irrational
part as well but have a look at this
lucky reason you've got our root 2 here
and another insurer there those the
irrational bit and when you put this all
together when you expand you would
expect to simplify there for you Richard
Hydra - it's just going to give you 2 so
you've got going to get rational bus
parts that are going to simplify with
these we're sure not is exactly what
happens ok I'm pretty happy with that
number let's have a look at this 1 over
2 simple interest you how to look at
last week you'll give them three numbers
if you have a look at each question this
which is what we call this it has a
special name after the P record is the
principal in fact if you wrote down a
question I really like labeling what
what either the equation I'll eat a
question so I go where I'm selling
stomach in this 2.5 percent what does
that represent
that's an interest rate right so we
usually humans operate to indicate that
mostly you can't give it a final
ingredient and for Part A Part B I'll
give you two different ones this for
years what we need to try better the
non-political yes we tend to write that
as number of time periods because as you
can see there are some times differently
so now you can see if this light here
850 0.05 is for that's P and our time
and your group pleasures okay dollars
heads up if you've got that yes
fantastic thank you business that was
the easy part
I will point out this question is about
the different interests at Big Bird not
the total about that you have at the end
if I asked you that question of set
what's the total amount that this person
had yeah you're going to have to add the
principal to the interest so just be
careful what do they actually offer
right now this last time let's have a
look together consolidations to be so
working before we get to be awesome
right all the time
okay so right suggesting that the 850 is
going to stay the same the 0.035 is
going to stay to stay and it's this part
that changes now he suggested 15 over 12
I wonder if so what else gets just why
that's a shuffle thing to put in there
yeah Ellen could it's like 12 months and
like this whole month in here they never
totally laughing okay so what you're
really doing is you got to correct by
the way you are converting this not true
me two months to some other youth but
you're trying to convert it into years
you want to learn how many years are
there is just a book I think it's one
and a quarter yeah okay yeah quick
question why are we convert it into
years why not say weeks or quarters or
what is it that makes years and
important time period
aha so pH rate per annum means annually
right we just turn at it and you know
top of the seg word so if it's interest
rate is per gr then I want to get my
time period also per year so even though
it's just two tiny letters very very
different I could have changed this
question to be something up like segment
0.5% per month if that were the case if
that were the case this question could
be quite different isn't it
what would I do here but if they both I
need to change that do i the interest
rate is in Lux the time periods in month
indoor group okay as it is once changing
in so what do you get is your number at
the bottom alright daddy do you just
around that yeah right yeah yeah yeah
battery one night great so we rounded to
the nearest it is perfect just before
you leave you'll often get questions
like this where lots of things you would
save and then you've got this slight
modification right before you head off
and close the book I just want to do a
bit of a final check on this right
everywhere we have widespread agreement
on 119 and I think most of you are
pretty confident in that number now
let's copy this number and I saw a lot
of different authors as I walked around
is this basically what you'd expect if
you know that part a is right that one
it exactly up there like one of the
court is it's about a third of this time
period do you agree about it's not
exactly first answer and this sure
enough is about a third of the original
interesting chapter does that make sense
so using additional bits to make
yourself a little more confident